ok ragazzi dai gusti pazzi ma ora tutti
e benvenuti che questo nuovo episodio di
amazing from allora solo una rana con un
telefono ed esso vi spiego questo gioco
ragazzi io l'ho fatto
quattro anni fa va bene non l'ho più
fatto e ci sarà un motivo che l'hanno
veramente aggiornato ma non so cosa
hanno aggiornato la ga pure talmente la
grafica e potente
se pensate come siamo messi veramente un
gioco strano posso spararmi dal cannone
voglio spararvi bravo aiuto ok a vai di
sopra perché lo spara ecco come il
nostro vedendo c'è una rana spiaccicata
su un tetto salve scusi è a lei ma cos'è
e vabbè il gioco dell'anno
allora mi fai uscire di qua però è bravo
la mia flautolenza mida capacità di volo
il tè incredibile sfido chiunque a dire
che non porto giochi di qualità palloni
a farlo mi ricordo neanche l'ultima
volta che ci ho giocato così è successo
per attenzione come gad magic johnson
porca vacca e come la lancia la palla mi
sa l'ho fatto l'ho fatto
poi non è così proprio in realtà però fa
niente male mi piace un sacco sound
effect che hanno messo quando porri e
soprattutto il fatto che i gradini più
casti e continui a slide aree cartella
come se non ci fosse un domani ma vedo
un sacco di rampe in giro il che
significa che io volendo posso prendere
una macchina magari volando che modo più
veloce
eccola perfetto dimmi che posso guidare
non mi ricordo in realtà è posso guidare
eccolo non sono noi marino
aspettiamo al volante dall'altra parte
perché ci siamo ci siamo sto guidando
l'agec septic ai mobili devo solo
trovare il modo di approcciare la rampa
che l'ho vista per ecco la thatcher
un'altra carminati sarà un altro seggio
attenzione dovete toni come cosa
cosa è successo toglietevi pia bravi
chiaro questo gioco non ha un senso lato
siamo dentro da cittadini di
dell'attacco di giganti ma che è sta
roba ko perfetto tutto a posto questa
mia esame di guida posso guidare anche
l'autobus
secondo me è un amico piantati simmons a
buongiorno se volevano avere la giornata
buongiorno
eccolo juta o barbieri ed è certo ma
cosa vi serve un barbiere consiglio i
capelli sono una rana ecco qua l'autobus
volete un passaggio no no dovete entrare
dentro va bene fate qualunque cosa c'è
scritto mai è vero un segno ecco questa
rassegna ai e massa che si fa un
cartello
mi scusi
e un gioco non family friendly per le
famiglie di rane perché per il resto lo
è
mi dispiace un sacco non volevo fare
questa roba però mi ha costretto aveva
un cutter che è successo santas grotto
sa cos'è sto casino
cos'è ac come un altro livello
fantasy tratto le grotte di babbo natale
va bene il set venete questo è un golf
simulator senza le capre ma con le rane
praticamente stessa roba se lo slittino
guida nutriti ma no
bravo vai ovviamente lo senti non ha il
motore quindi non ha senso
prendi lo slittino predicò ha fatto
tutto lui non ho fatto niente benvenuto
addosso ma levatevi chi siete
ciò lo slittino quindi teoricamente
basta che io mi metta vitti puoi
togliere che mi dà fastidio
basta che rimette a sopra e poi scendo a
tutta velocità by l'udc o mio dio
al contrario si sono i paletti che sfiga
va beh devo fare la stessa cosa
dall'altra pago e bellissimo a una
fisica sto gioco che sfido tutto quello
che ho studiato alle superiori di fisica
cioè niente
tutte queste grosso muro rela
c'è uno slittino dentro la testa è tutto
a posto tranquilli ragazzi è normale è
così che si facciano sentire che non lo
sapete voi ma si va da un segno io
dunque slide o molto più veloce così che
normalmente come possibile sfondato due
cose dove fa niente se c'è scritto lì
croca cola no vabbè ragazzi cioè io
penso che sia il gioco più geniale della
storia ho notato ragazzi che le targhe
delle macchine sono tutti i nomi di
youtuber che hanno portato questo gioco
come tributo a loro l'hanno li hanno
messi nelle targhe delle macchine prima
gex epica e poi c'è anche pd pie l'ho
visto eccolo qua queste bici bike trail
deep bellissimo e li hanno messi come
tributo il discorso è che anche io ho
portato questo gioco
ai tempi no l'ho portato ha fatto anche
un miliardo di views perché era piaciuta
tantissimo quindi può essere che io ci
sia come tributo controllo tutte le
macchine dei certo che i ragazzi ho
controllato tutte le targhe delle
macchine e in realtà e non ci sono
neanche in una quindi stavo per sparare
allegramente merda su questo gioco visto
che non mi hanno ringraziato gli ingrati
però mi sono permesso di alzare lo
sguardo e mi hanno messo sul cinema
prova a uscire dalla mappa ragazzi in
quanto per quanto non riuscirò mai
perché il muro è troppo alto ci voglio
provare
però sono arrivato a metà mi scusi in
questo momento problemi con la macchina
che mi dà una mano per favore mi scusi
lei non mi volti le spalle maledetto è
morto ti prego fatemi uscire la stampa
come si esce anche neanche con la
propulsione restare fuori dal comune
dove marco del demonio vi sono
incastrato
l'hack volevo andare a giocare a scacchi
è tutto sto casino fame d'aria che
l'aspettano sono curiosi di vedere come
fuori porca vacca non posso andarci
fuori purtroppo a meno che questi casi
non vi dia la propulsione non penso ma
non si sa mai proviamo muoversi si
muovono ma non credo diano propulsione a
sto punto va bene in teoria e ci sono le
basi per un gioco online in tutto sto
casino perché da solo ste cose qua non
le puoi fare il che è molto triste
però non so se esiste un live meglio di
no forse tensione ho vinto io
perfetto sono bravissimo no come è
risorto il re cosa ma la fan a non può
risorgere ma il 6 per terra a posto
niente ho vinto io ragazzi non c'è verso
e comunque ragazzi tutto questo abbiamo
dimenticato la nostra missione
principale che è questa no non andare
sulla toledo andare sugli come faccio
arrivare al dirigibile
non ci posso rimanere impossibile a meno
che io non mi non faccia una perché
prima all'inizio ero andato mi ricordo
sull'altro tetto e dall'altro detto
c'era un altro ventilatore quindi forse
da liriche scuola arrivarci io sono non
lo spiego ci deve essere un modo per
toccare dice comunque ragazzi si e gta
che ha visto gioco quasi c'è in entrambi
l'obiettivo lo stesso toccare il
dirigibile il che è incredibile lo vedo
che c'è un
ventilatore raggiunto sparti vai a posto
perfetto
salve è la sta facendo qua su bada a
controllare giocano i giorni lei
bravissimo play vedi che c'e un
ventilatore lì allora un modo o
nell'altro
mi ha inglobato in modo incredibile non
pensavo mai potesse buttare il gruppo
orco demonio verso rifaccia a eccola lei
è il karma il karma è stato il karma
sicuro sott'acqua dentro parte james
posso entrare in palestra come fosse
taipana palestra delle rane ove farvi
provare la palestra e poi provato cane
dirigibile perché credo credo che
qualsiasi ha sorpassato un attimo il
limite del trash ma non ne sono
pienamente convinto però panca piana no
beh sono morti tutti sono morti tutti
non fa niente e tapis roulants come
cacchio faccio perfetto ok corri e vedi
che era facile niente siamo così c'è di
tour al ring no ragazzi vi prego ditemi
che si può giocare un la lava donna sono
ci sono dei morti in piscina nessuno se
n'è accorto e teoricamente visto che io
conosco un po la fisica perché lo la
studia i a suo tempo se butti un qualche
cosa di elettronico nella piscina
dovrebbero morire tutti folgorati quindi
parco demanio abili oggi questa roba
fortunatamente la possiamo anche a
bloggare bella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo blog oggi
proveremo a ammazzare qualcuno nella
piscina aspetta no questa abbastanza
elettrico da fondersi in tuta penso di
sì ciao
non è successo niente
che peccato ci sarà un sacco allora come
cacchio faccio a passare di qua devo
saltare il suo pezzo perfetto
non so no piano ok no perchè questo qua
per girare ok ce l'ho fatta vediamo se
adesso riesco in qualche modo a
lanciarli sul cosa può essere ma non vi
prometto nulla perfetto marò arrivabile
ricevano trampolino qua magari con
trappolino resto magari capresi fa
saltare incredibilmente in alto
mi sa di no
ok ancora di più e fate fatta e lo so
piace ai piú tizio sopra non avevo visto
ce l'ho fatta perfetto ragazzi avevo
finito questa era questa queste per me è
tutto
obiettivo del gioco completato signori
questa era di amazing frodi un gioco il
candidato all'oscar grazie di avermelo
di qualche qualcuni come sei riuscito
perché non fa ieri e non rifai dei mezzi
in frodi di infatti mette dato un
consiglio incredibile se avete altre
porcate che potrei riportare sul canale
ditemelo perché sicuramente ve le porto
io spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzo nei
miei come se siete al canale e noi ci
vediamo come sempre al prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]